[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire joe biden est il en train de
mettre fin à 40 ans de néolibéralisme
l'ampleur de son plan de relance et sans
précédent on parle de new new deal et il
est en partie destinée à réduire les
inégalités
by denver on augmenter les impôts des
plus riches et augmenter les impôts des
entreprises et il veut qu'ils augmentent
partout pas seulement aux états unis
dans le monde entier alors joe biden est
il un gilet jaune ou un produit de la
gilet jaune isation du monde en trois
mois il a mis sur la table un quart de
la richesse américaine
va-t-il réussir à terrasser l'hydre
néolibérale pour en débattre nous avons
invité françois boulot il est avocat
il vous vous êtes fait puisque vous
apparaissez vous vous êtes fait
connaître en tant que porte-parole des
filets jaunes de rouen aujourd'hui vous
avez créé praxis une chaîne de télé sur
youtube et vous publiez reprendre le
pouvoir aux éditions les liens qui
libèrent c'est un manuel d'émancipation
politique politique dans le prolongement
de votre engagement dans le mouvement
des gilet jaune
vous pensez que joe biden est une sorte
de gilet jaune d'honneur quand trois
mois il a il a réalisé tout ce dont vous
rêviez je serais plutôt nuancé d'une
part déjà parce que l'une des deux
revendications principales des gilet
jaune c'était la question démocratique
avec le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et à cet égard aux jo byden ne
prend aucune mesure pour démocratiser
plus les institutions américaines et
ensuite sur la question je dirais
économique et social je crois que on
assiste effectivement aux états unis à
une rupture avec la politique qui a été
menée depuis 40 ans l'initiative au
départ de ronald reagan
maintenant je crois qu'il faut être
prudent je suis pas certain que joe
biden est en train de réaliser l'idéal
de justice fiscale et sociale qui était
revendiqué par les gilets jaunes
olivier babeau vous êtes économiste
président de l'institut sapiens que vous
avez fondé avec laurent alexandre et
dominical mels vous écrivait
régulièrement dans les échos dans
l'opinion et dans le figaro vous êtes
l'auteur de plusieurs livres dont la
nouvelle ferme des animaux en 2016 ou le
nous
au désordre numérique comment le digital
a fait exploser les inégalités qui est
paru à la rentrée chez buchet chastel
alors est ce que est ce que vous voyez
vous une rupture est ce que est ce que
tout ce que vous redoutiez joe biden est
en train de le réaliser
je redoutais pas nécessairement alors
pour savoir s'il fait le programme de
gilet jaune il faudrait déjà avoir une
idée claire de ce que voulaient les
idées jaune et je pense qu'un des
problèmes c'était que c'était pas tout à
fait certain ce qui est sûr c'est que
joe biden a fait le diagnostic de la
polarisation du monde et une
polarisation qui est très très visible
aux états unis il essaye d'y apporter
des réponses
est ce que ces réponses vont avoir du
succès on le verra pas ce qu'il faut ça
implique des réformes importantes des
institutions une plus grande efficacité
de l'état des investissements en fait
effectivement qui n'ont pas été faits
afin que ça soit plus efficace
et puis après la réforme fiscale en fait
elle et elle est relativement légère
même si sa marque effectivement un vrai
tournant oui parce que c'est quand même
ça fait 40 ans quasiment que les impôts
des plus riches baisse ses effets qu'à
40 ans quasiment que les impôts des
entreprises baisse et cela partout dans
le monde
ils ont considérablement devait baisser
dans tout le cd eu au cours des vingt
dernières années il ya une sorte de dan
ping il ya une concurrence fiscale qui
veut que chacun baisse des impôts la
france est encore en train de baisser
ses impôts sur les sociétés en faillite
est tellement haut que
on arrive juste à peine je crois en
dessous de ce qui est prévu par joe
biden la ja il ya une vraie rupture
quand tout à coup on veut taxer les plus
riches et de taxer les entreprises
il ya déjà une rupture avec ce que l'on
a appelé à tort ou à raison le
néolibéralisme et non françois boulot
oui alors je crois que ce qui est le
plus significatif dans le plan de joe
biden c'est surtout que premièrement il
ne revient pas sur le retour au
protectionnisme qu'à initier donald
trump et ensuite il a il fait un plan de
relance massif effectivement 2,5 fois la
relance qui est prévu pour par l'union
européenne et ça c'est véritablement une
rupture avec la doctrine du libre marché
qui je veux dire spontanément répondrait
aux intérêts particuliers et à l'intérêt
général
donc là on voit que les américains de ce
point de vue là ils sont beaucoup plus
pragmatique que ils défendent leur
compétitivité économique et que donc
s'il faut mettre de l'argent en faisant
tourner la planche à billets ils y vont
et on a un autre élément qui
effectivement je pense qu'à la suite de
du mandat de trump et des événements du
capitole qui ont achevé le mandat de
donald trump on a des classes dominantes
aux états unis et je pense ont compris
qu'il fallait lâcher un peu de lest
vis-à-vis des classes populaires et des
classes moyennes
et donc on retrouve dans le plan de joe
biden des aides financières aux ménages
mais des aides qui sont finalement
temporaire et qui dans quelques mois ne
seront plus là et donc finalement est ce
qu'il ya vraiment une réforme
structurelle de la répartition de la
richesse aux états unis et avec une
volonté véritablement de réduire les
inégalités
je serais plutôt mesurés parce que
effectivement sur la réforme fiscale
en réalité il faut se rappeler que
avant l élection de donald trump le taux
d'imposition sur les sociétés il était à
35 % et la job hayden ne fait simplement
que de reporter ce taux me à 21 % par
donald trump à 28%
donc en fait on revient à un taux qui
était de toute façon inférieur à celui
de 2016 on est très loin des taux
d'imposition qu'on a connu dans la
période de la seconde guerre mondiale ou
même le post seconde guerre mondiale aux
états unis qui montaient jusqu'à 90%
on était encore à 70% sous nixon et même
se régale on était encore à 50% de taux
d'imposition donc c'est vrai que depuis
des années 70-80 n'avait une baisse
continue du taux d'imposition d'haydn
rompt avec cette baisse continue mais
finalement on est quand même encore très
loin des taux d'imposition qu'on
pratiquait je dirai au milieu du xxème
siècle aux états unis ce qui veut dire
que l'on peut donner un bon point aux
américains c'est que au moins
contrairement à l'union européenne
eux ils sont pragmatiques et quand il
faut relancer l'économie il n'hésite pas
à faire tourner la planche à billets et
à mettre des investissements des
dépenses publiques massives pour la
compétitivité
en revanche pour ce qui est de résoudre
les inégalités sociales et économiques
au sein des états unis au sein des
classes populaires classe moyenne bon on
est encore quand même assez loin de
résoudre ces problématiques la même si
le retour au protectionnisme déjà
favorise ces classes là parce qu'on on
argue localiser des emplois aux
etats-unis et donc ordonnant de l'emploi
évidemment ces classes populaires et
classes moyennes qui était hier
délaissés et mis à l'abandon retrouve
enfin du travail la possibilité de
s'insérer dans la société
je précise juste avant de donner la
parole olivier babeau que à l'époque des
de l'imposition à 90% ou à 70%
ça ne concernait que la dernière tranche
de revenus on imposait pas sur
l'ensemble des revenus à 90%
sinon il y aurait jamais en finale
nelson rockefeller donc on pouvait quand
même gagner de l'argent aux états unis
est la raison pour lesquelles on faisait
ça et qu'on l'a plus fait après pas
c'est peut-être lié à l'existence de
l'union soviétique et de parti
communiste qui représentait quand même
une tentation pour les ouvriers les
classes populaires et pas seulement en
europe aux etats unis aussi
olivier babeau oui d'abord je ne sais
pas si protectionnisme est vraiment en
dans l'intérêt réel des classes les plus
modestes parce que ça ça enrichit en
fait les importations et et les produits
donc ça c'est bon ça c'est évidemment un
autre débat je crois qu'il faut se
garder d' évaluer la qualité d'un état
en fonction de l'importance de ces
prélèvements
d'ailleurs sur l'idée que les
prélèvements ont baissé partout c'est
paca c'est pas le cas en france par
exemple et il ya un très bon article
dans le financial times aujourd'hui qui
explique justement que la baisse de la
présence de l'état est un mythe depuis
quarante ans que ce n'est pas vrai
l'état ne s'est pas retiré là il a
changé de forme il est toujours aussi
présent il est plus présent que jamais
par exemple à travers les politiques
monétaires puisqu'il a fini par remettre
la main sur la banque centrale qui
finalement c'est ce que les états lui
demande donc c'est encore plus vrai en
france par les néo libéralisme en france
et est une est une blague absolument
incroyable ça quand on regarde les
chiffres il n'y a jamais eu néolibérale
ça fait 40 ans aujourd'hui qu'on aligne
un budget en déficit de plus en plus en
déficit avec une dette qui ne fait
qu'augmenter donc ya jamais eu de baisse
de dépenses
il ya juste eu malheureusement de
l'argent qui est pour le moins mal le
mal employé alors quand on parle de
néolibéralisme très souvent en réalité
on sait pas très bien de porc en bas et
en fait derrière on parle du capitalisme
de connivence c'est ça probablement l'un
des défauts des états unis il ya un très
bon livre de l'économiste thomas
philippon récemment de droite rivarol
qui a très très bien montré comment les
états unis avaient depuis une vingtaine
d'années abandonné justement est bien la
concurrence en laissant les
concentrations se sert évidemment les
gars femmes en sont l'expression la plus
la plus ultime et c'est évidemment des
concentrations qui nuisent au marché
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on dit
on ne remet jamais en cause la victoire
par ko sur le communisme du libre marché
de la libre entreprise dont il est même
pas question de la remettre en cause
et ça finalement c'est quand même le
substrat du libéralisme donc peut-être
que le tournant de bayonne c'est
justement le plus intéressant c'est pas
celui forcément qu'on dit le plus dur
c'est pas forcément le tournant fiscale
qui en effet est un peu en un retour à
ce qui a déjà été fait mais c'est cette
idée que on va peut-être enfin essayer
de faire pièce aux
grande plate forme quasi monopolistique
qui se développent et ça c'est très
intéressant je signe je n'ai que trump
avait commencé la distribution d'argent
new deal est ce qu'un un américain il a
touché environ il a eut reçu directement
par vers man sur son compte bancaire
environ trois mille balles un an notre
mille dollars
n'importe quel américain sans conditions
de revenus et ça ça avait commencé déjà
avec trump donc il faut pas imaginer que
c'est bayonne qui est le père noël qui
arrive et après le méchant trip c'est
pas ça l'histoire
oui mais alors il faut quand même
préciser que lorsqu'ils concernent
baydan il y à deux mille milliards de
dollars qui sont destinés aux plus
défavorisés 1 et qui vont être
véritablement distribués alors là
justement sous condition de revenus ces
destinées aux plus défavorisés
c'est véritablement destiné à lutter
contre les inégalités et puis on sait
maintenant qu'il va y avoir un troisième
plan le deuxième plan ça concerne les
infrastructures qui ont beaucoup vieilli
aux états unis et depuis longtemps donc
on va réparer les routes ça c'est
vraiment l'aspect grands travaux à la
roosevelt comme le new deal en 1932 au
moment de la grande dépression
et puis à une troisième partie qui vient
d'être annoncée qui a fait d'ailleurs
baisser la bourse c'est qu'il ya un
troisième plan entre 1000 et 1500
milliards de dollars
là qui va être consacré à la famille à
l'enfance aux crèches peut-être même
instauré des allocations familiales
donc là ce serait encore une fois
véritablement destiné
quand même à creuser les inégalités à
rétablir du service public public à
remettre l'état au centre du jeu on est
quand même dans une dans un changement
d'optique considérable françois boulot
j'ai répondu à cette question en disant
de chance qu effectivement les
américains sont en train d'être
pragmatique pour relancer la compétition
enfin la compétitivité économique de
leur pays
en revanche sur la question des
inégalités les mesures vous évoquez
elles sont plutôt temporaire c'est pas
des réformes véritablement structurelles
jeu-là répondre à ce que a dit olivier
babeau parce que je pense qu à plusieurs
contre vérités ou en tout cas une vision
du monde assez réductrice
la première chose c'est que sur le
protectionnisme on nous dit oui mais ça
élève le coût des importations mais
c'est bien ça le problème en fait c'est
depuis 30 ou 40 ans toutes les
politiques elles sont menées avec le
prisme du consommateur il faut que le
consommateur paye moins puisque le
problème c'est que quand vous faites pas
de protectionnisme est en train de
détruire l'appareil de production dans
votre pays vous avez plus de
travailleurs alors on fait le choix du
consommateur est pas celui du
travailleur sauf que si les gens ne
travaillent pas un moment donné ils ont
plus de pouvoir d'achat ils peuvent plus
acheter les produits peuvent plus
acheter les produits importés
donc ça c'est havas et c'est la chose
qu'il faut comprendre et le retour au
protectionnisme
c'est ce qui permet de maintenir le
niveau de vie des classes populaires et
des classes moyennes est la seule
solution en réalité si vous voulez
véritable enfer le choix du libre
échange ce serait de compenser par ce
que avec des politiques mais steve
fiscal de redistribution en imposant
très fortement les plus riches sauf que
dans le cadre du libre échange
on a eu une explosion si de l'évasion
fiscale donc en fait on est perdant sur
tous les tableaux
c'est pour ça qu'un retour au
protectionnisme ça me paraît être une
bonne chose et en ce sens des américains
sont en train de montrer la voie ensuite
olivier babeau disait qu' on n'a jamais
été dans le néolibéralisme en france
mais c'est une blague
alors moi ces raisonnements là ils
m'agacent toujours parce que on fait
comme si on devait partir d'une page
blanche mais non en fait la france a une
histoire
c'est un pays et on ne vient pas de
nulle part on vient de la faim dans une
guerre mondiale les institutions les
instances aujourd'hui qui qui existe
c'est la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale et on a eu notamment le système
de protection sociale issues du conseil
national de l'arize
notamment et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
vous l'avez très justement dit frédéric
taddeï c'est que notamment à partir du
moment où il ya eu la chute du mur de
berlin l'effondrement de l'urss
le rapport de force des classes
dominantes vis-à-vis de la population
s'est totalement déséquilibrée en faveur
de qui des classes dominantes parce
qu'il y avait effectivement une
tentation de la population des classes
populaires a basculé dans le communisme
à partir du moment où cette menace n'est
plus alors le rapport de force
déséquilibré totalement est en fait le
néo libéralisme n'est que la traduction
des râpes du rapport de force qui s'est
déséquilibré en faveur des élites et qui
leur a permis d'akkad d'accroître leur
prédation sur la richesse produite et
donc en france ça se traduit comment ça
te sera due par des classes dominantes
qui depuis trente ans ne prennent que
des mauvaises décisions nous envoie dans
le mur économiquement parce que il ya
les principes il ya la réalité la
réalité c'est que la croissance dans le
pays elle n'arrête pas de dégringoler
sur la dernière décennie on est
péniblement à 0 15%
le pib par habitant depuis 2008 ils
baissent de manière tendancielle et on a
ensuite deux éléments clés à prendre en
compte
1 les uns ou les 0 1% les plus riches
n'arrête pas d'exploser leurs revenus et
dans le même temps on a la population
française qui pour au moins 30 % d'entre
elles connaît une baisse du niveau de
vie au moins 30% parce que les chiffres
de l'insee sont peut-être sous-évalué
notamment dans la prise en compte de
l'inflation et du du coût de
l'immobilier
voilà la réalité et cette baisse du
niveau de vie elle va s'accentuer dans
les années à venir parce que comme on a
cassé notre appareil productif français
on ne pourra pas maintenir dans l'avenir
notre niveau de richesse
notre ni le niveau de vie de la
population et pourquoi on est en système
libéral est tout simplement parce qu'on
est dans l'union européenne et que
l'union européenne consacre le libre
échange via le marché unique dont qu'on
vienne m'expliquer qu'il n'y a pas de
dérégulation alors que le point central
du néolibéralisme c'est le libre échange
la mise en concurrence des pays les uns
envers les autres
quand bien même ces les niveaux de
développement de ces pays sont très
hétérogènes et donc en l'état pour
revenir à des choses très concrètes on a
un salaire minimum qui nous est à 1500
euros et on s'est mis en concurrence
libre échangiste avec la pologne par
exemple qui est un salaire minimum à 500
euros
comment voulez vous qu'on retienne les
entreprises françaises en france quand
les propriétaires ces entreprises
peuvent aller fabriquer leurs produits
trois ou quatre fois moins cher
dans un pays étranger juste je mets miss
je pose la question et olivier babeau
françois boulot insiste en disant à part
du moment où il ya la fin du communiste
y aller c'est le triomphe des élites
dominantes
c'est le triomphe des élites tout c'est
le triomphe du marché le marché
l'emportent
il emporte partout dans le monde même en
chine où ils sont toujours communiste
politique l'eau mais les élites les
élites françaises sont fracassés par le
marché autant que les travailleurs et au
fond le marché profite aux consommateurs
parfois aux classes populaires comme aux
classes plus aisées mais le marché
triomphe pas les élites olivier des
loyers d'ailleurs si on me prend un peu
là la focale en fait le libéralisme a
tiré au sens propre des milliards de
gens de la pauvreté c'est à dire que
c'est grâce à ça sauf qu'ils n'étaient
pas chez nous et qu'en effet il ya eu un
choc thermique terry parce qu'on avait
cette espèce d'équilibré qui étaient
liés à des marchés qui était plus petit
et qui ont fait que quand on s'est
ouvert vers des pays où évidemment le
coût du travail était différent on a
perdu très rapidement et ça a été en
effet très douloureux et c'est que c'est
un problème réel
une partie des emplois pour pour notre
notre main d'oeuvre ce qui se passe au
plus aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec le
numérique il ya une accélération la
disparition des employés de me qualifier
au profit d'emplois très qualifiés et
puis du reste d'emplois peu qualifiés et
donc ça pose un problème de de
polarisation qui c'est qui est observé
dans toutes les sociétés développées
c'est pas nécessairement lié au fait
qu'on soit ouvert mais c est liée aussi
aux évolutions technologiques sur le
fait que ça se voit la fin du communisme
et que ça soit la conséquence d'une
bataille fin d'une d'une domination des
élites je pense que ça fait partie d'une
interprétation qui vous qui vous qui
vous appartient je pense corrélation
n'est pas causalité donc je vous laisse
là là je vous laisse la responsabilité
de cette interprétation moi je je
constate en tout cas qu'en effet on a
cette polarisation dans mon livre c'est
ce que je fais je constate cette
augmentation la polarisation qui est pas
nécessairement le but d'une volonté
méchante de l'un ou l'autre je pense que
personne ne tire ne tire les ficelles je
pense que c'est la cet la façon dont cet
agrandissement de marché mondial cette
plaie est en effet créé un choc
thermique qui nécessite une évolution de
placement une option de positionnement
pardon si aujourd'hui on n'a plus les
moyens de financer le système social de
plus généraux du monde qui est celui de
la france c'est parce que on a pu le
positionnement d'un effet pas fait les
bonnes réformes on a probablement laissé
l'industrie mûri on l'a laissé
l'industrie partir en pensant qu'on
pouvait vivre uniquement de service on
n'a pas réussi à réellement démocratisé
la formation et à et à former les gens
et à les faire monter en compétences et
c'est ça aujourd'hui qu'on paye parce
que si on a pu les compétences dans ce
marché mondial il est totalement
illusoire de penser qu'on va pouvoir
fermer les frontières et vivent entre
nous sauf à renoncer à une très très
grande partie de notre niveau de vie et
de notre confort des services et des
produits auxquels on a pris l'habitude
et bien si on se forme pas ses problèmes
aussi des états unis on arrivera tout
simplement plus à financer tout ça voilà
françois un boulot même question est ce
que vous ne faites pas de la démagogie
quand vous incriminez les élites alors
que les élites notamment en france ont
très souvent été victime du marché
le marché a triomphé souvent il a
triomphé sur les états d'ailleurs sur
les états dation mai mais il a aussi
triomphé sur nos élites qui étaient
parfois des grands industriels et qui ne
sont plus aujourd'hui des grands
industriels qui ont tout perdu dans
l'histoire et je crois que vous posez il
ya une question fondamentale évidemment
à qu'elle est très dur de réponse et la
course effectivement entre le marché les
états nations et on voit bien que c'est
depuis trente ou quarante ans le marché
qui est en train de prendre tout le
pouvoir et finalement de rendre
impuissants les états mais je crois
qu'il faut dans cette dynamique là il
faut prendre en compte que les élites en
tout cas françaises ont très largement
accompagné ce mouvement
quand vous avez une vague de
privatisations dans les années 1980 1990
je veux dire les élites elles sont pas
obligées de privatiser toutes les
banques elles sont pas obligées de
privatiser les assurances elles sont pas
obligées de privatiser les les fleurons
industriels du pays
tout ça c'est bien des décisions des
élites françaises de la même manière les
élites n'était pas obligé de se mettre
dans l'euro et d'essayer de s'adosser au
deutsche mark allemand pour finalement
essayer de garantir un niveau de vie à
court terme mais pour sacrifier
l'industrie française à long terme on à
sacrifier notre avenir en s'arrimant à
l'euro
et ça tout le monde le savait je veux
dire philippe seguin l'avait annoncé
jean pierre chevènement l'avait annoncé
tous les gens à peu près sérieux les
intellectuels aussi je pense notamment
emmanuel todd avait annoncé que l'euro
c'est 3 ou 4 à strophes vais d'ailleurs
même des économistes néolibéraux comme
milton friedman avait annoncé que l'euro
sera une catastrophe
et quand arrêter les divergences
d'intérêts entre les états de l'union
européenne allait créer des
déséquilibres qui serait insurmontable
c'est ce à quoi on assiste et donc si
vous voulez de la même manière qu'on se
met dans le marché unique et qu'on
s'interdit de faire des aides d'état aux
entreprises qu'on s'interdise réservé
les marchés publics aux entreprises
françaises qu'on s'interdit donc d'avoir
des règlements commerciaux de faire du
protectionnisme
est ce que vous voulez on ne fait plus
aucune politique économique ont
abandonné tous ne deviez de souveraineté
monétaire et commerciaux donc bien sûr
que la dynamique déjà elle est assez en
faveur du marché qui étaient de plus en
plus puissants mais si en plus de ça
vous avez des classes dominantes qui se
soumettent docilement spontanément et
volontairement en marche et il est
évident que on va jamais à gagner cette
course et que la démocratie perdra face
aux multinationales
olivier babeau oui si un des enjeux
importants et c'est justement un enjeu
je pense du retour du libéralisme dont
on a besoin ou de l'arrivée du
libéralisme cas par cas pas vraiment eu
lieu en réalité c'est que on a besoin en
effet d'un état qui soit un état présent
et qui soit un état capable de faire
pièce effectivement par exemple aux
emplois qui s'appelait les
multinationales mais donc des
plateformes monopolisant tu es des
entreprises qui ont des pouvoirs de
marché assez important on s'est rendu
compte avec cette crise de l'importance
d'un état qui soit efficace par exemple
on s'est rendu compte de la
bureaucratisation d'une partie de notre
santé de sa difficulté à s'adapter donc
l'idée d'un état qui soit plus réactif
plus flexible plus en prise avec le réel
d'un état aussi qu'ils soient capables
de travailler avec le privé donné il ya
un super exemple récemment c'est la
fusée d'elon musk le son travail avec la
nasa va vous savez que c'est ronald
reagan qui a imputé sa carrière impulsé
7,7
ce changement de travail ce changement
de façon travail dans la nasa qui de
plus en plus s'est mise à travailler
avec il s'est mis à mis en compétition
rang concurrence des entreprises privées
qui d'ailleurs du coup supporte une
grosse partie du risque et c'est ça
qui fait aujourd'hui le succès assez
extraordinaire qui n'est pas chez nous
donc non c'est pas parce qu'on a
privatisé d'ailleurs les privatisations
venait après des nationalisations il
faut s'en tenir il faut regarder que
dans les entreprises nationalisées si
vous regardez leur bilan en général la
plupart du temps leur leur stratégie et
a été catastrophique parce que l'état
est un actionnaire totalement
contradictoire qui passe son temps à la
fois apprendre beaucoup de dividendes
qui sait pas exactement ce qu'il veut
qui veut pas qu'ils quitteraient nul
pour pour faire évoluer les entreprises
c'est pas là si ce n'est pas à l'état
d'avoir ces entreprises pensant que
c'est à l'état et ça c'est vraiment son
rôle et faut pas confondre libéralisme
et anarchisme il faut un état fort un
état capable de sans doute avoir une
stratégie sans doute de créer un cadre
qui soit qui permette à chacun d'avoir
sa chance et aux entreprises de se
développer
c'est l'enjeu aujourd'hui parce que
évidemment le cadre réglementaire doit
évoluer sous sous l'effet du numérique
qui fait que les règles
la façon dont la la la valeur se capter
secrets ont profondément changé et c'est
une des difficultés on peut vraiment pas
faire ça de malheureusement au niveau
français est là le niveau européen est
très important oui françois boulot oui
alors je pense j'entends
bureaucratisation lourdeur de l'état
qu'il faudra flexibiliser mais c'est
toujours les mêmes poncifs
il faut arrêter avec ça comme si l'état
était par nature mauvais et le et et le
marché et le temps et c'est formidable
et le marché serait formidable mais
c'est toujours les mêmes quartiers ce qu
on entend maintenant des messieurs vous
monsieur vous avez vous les êtes vous
les avez entendus les soignants est ce
que vous les avez entendus les soignants
il n'y a pas de moyens ils sont pas
assez nombreux moi j'ai dû aller aux
urgences il ya longtemps par les amis y
avait pas de brancards son n'y a même
pas de branche car aux urgences pour
installer des gens à monsieur s'adresser
à l'état s'ils sont pas contents c'est
pas au marché il ya aucun marché dont la
santé on a complètement brisé le 6 mai
lam et les lieux mais vraiment vous
plaisantez
vous n'avez pas compris quelle manière
non mais vous avez pas compris qu
emmanuel macron avait donné 30 milliards
de réductions d'impôts aux 20% les plus
riches
et quand en ce temps-là il a baissé le
budget des hôpitaux de la justice de
l'éducation nationale et que tous ces
services publics essentiels du canada
ctc ont cent du pnb
ça n'a pas bougé
on n'a pas défendu c'est un mythe ah oui
est un mythe et pareil pour les accords
ne dépense pas moi et les besoins santé
ne demande pas et les besoins santé
augmentent pas avec le vieillissement de
la population et la démographique vous
pensez qu'on peut rester à budget
constant
le pib baisse en pourcentage du pib
donc cette idée que on a on a cassé on a
on a été horrible c'est pas vrai et si
vous regardez les prélèvements de l'état
elle la part de l'état dans le pib
c'est plus en plus fort donc non il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas d'assèchement et râlent
parce que ce que parce que le tassement
que vous dites est vrai mystère ça vous
dit et c'est pas bon alors je la
respecte a dit est ce que vous dites est
terminée françois boulot le raisonnement
parce que quand vous voyez chevauchant
donc une minute et on fait une pause la
parole m'avait été donné c'est c'est
assez compliqué de s'interrompt parce
que dans leur ya un temps pas très bien
ce que vous dites est faux parce que
vous ne prenez pas en compte la
démographie
voilà le problème et je vous invite à
aller dans les hôpitaux allait demander
aux soignants si ils ont trop de moyens
oscillent en ont pas assez prêt ne s'est
pas la bureaucratisation c'est lui s'il
n'y a pas de moyens humains il n'y a pas
de matériel aller travailler à l'hôpital
et puis après on en reparlera monsieur
je vous propose qu'on fasse une tombe
cinq heures et l'organisation du travail
aussi voilà maintenant vous pouvez faire
la pause on fait une pause et en france
débat
[Musique]
la nouvelle menace qui pèse sur
l'industrie une pénurie de matières
premières j'avais un phénomène qui est
le phénomène qui a fait monter tous les
actifs et qui ne sont pas forcément
d'actifs industriels des métaux ou autre
qui est l'inondation par les banques
centrales de monnaie et cette inondation
par les banques centrales de monnaie a
fait tout simplement grimper les prix
vous avez quand même un court terme avec
les livres namik entre l'offre et la
demande qui fait qu'avec le kobe 19 mai
les prix des matières premières se sont
d'abord alexandre est un syndicat sur le
pétrole et que l'on à une lente reprise
notamment parce qu'il ya un pays qui est
moins touchée que les autres qui est le
seul pays qui a fait de la croissance
économique
officiellement en 2001 qui est la chine
aujourd'hui c'est pas avec des
gesticulations en disant oh là là on va
manquer de telle ou telle matière
première le ca va relancer les choses et
que ça va permettre aux entreprises de
rouvrir
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières la première
c'est par la loi et ensuite progresser
parce que nous appelons des pratiques
professionnelles protectrice la justice
à sa part dans cette impunité comment
souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec françois boulot
et avec olivier babeau alors évidemment
on se pose la question de savoir si si
joe biden est en train de rompre avec
les fondamentaux du néo libéralisme tel
qu' il existe depuis une quarantaine
d'années et qu'il est et on le considère
qu il est imité aussi par boris johnson
d'ailleurs et on se demande si la france
n'est pas encore une fois à contretemps
comme elle l'était en 1980 au moment où
ronald reagan et margaret thatcher
arrive et au pouvoir en grande-bretagne
aux etats-unis nous on élisait de
françois mitterrand alors est-ce qu'on
serait encore aujourd'hui un contretemps
au moment où joe biden et boris johnson
serait en train de de rompre avec le
néolibéralisme là nous on continuerait
en france alors ça peut paraître un peu
un peu qu'un cas tu râles néanmoins
c'est ce qu'on lit ici et là alors
olivier babeau d'abord est-ce que vous
avez ce sentiment de ce décalage là
c'est vrai que on pourrait être à
contretemps et donc et ou plutôt décalé
très exactement donc on peut craindre
les prochaines élections puisque on a vu
que tellement de pays avait fait le
choix d'un d'un d'un candidat populiste
et on peut craindre que ce soit en effet
notre tour après bon on a en france le
système le plus redistributif du monde
et une note de l'insee très intéressante
qui a montré qu' on est le système le
plus égalitariste qui égalise le plus
sain avant redistribution si vous prenez
les 10% des revenus les plus hauts et
les plus bas
il ya un rapport en moyenne de 1 à 20 et
après redistribution c'est 2 1
un peu plus de 5 donc on a un régime
déjà puissamment redistributif donc en
fait nous on n'a jamais était comme les
états unis on en est extraordinairement
loin et quand on connaît un peu les
états unis on mesure la différence un
évidement du droit du travail de la
façon dont on envisage l'économie de la
place aussi de l'état donc pour tous et
pour toutes ces raisons
finalement nous depuis françois
mitterrand pas grand chose n'a changé à
dire les politiques de droite ont pas
changé grand chose alors on souvent
général elle freiner un petit peu
l'augmentation des dépenses mais enfin
fondamentalement
ça reste quand même assez assez
semblables c'est vrai il ya eu une
diminution de l'impôt sur la fortune un
cap à part a été supprimé il a juste été
coupé en partie et il faut se souvenir
d'ailleurs que les résultats économiques
avant le coc vide était très bon et y
compris sur le front du chômage qui
connaissait c'est plus grande baisse
depuis longtemps ça il faut il faut s'en
souvenir on l'a déjà oublié
vous y croyez françois boulot aux
chiffres que viennent donner olivier
babeau moi j'ai jamais cru après
redistribution deux à cinq mois je serai
des gens qui ont des écarts de 1 à 20
après redistribution
après impôts j'ai toujours trouvé ce
chiffre bizarre d'où sort-il en réalité
ces notes de l'hymne sais que je peux
vous donner si vous voulez mais vous
n'avez pas l'impression de connaître les
gens qui ont un écart de 1 à 20 entre
entremont les mêmes maps à grande pompe
et plus hauts et les plus bas
c'est une moyenne on peut dire que wyeth
est trompeuse
ouais c'est que la france représente 30
% de toutes les dépenses de
redistribution du monde elle toute seule
une manif au temps en temps il faut se
comparer ce rassurer un petit peu c'est
à dire voir la roya bhl force et
d'autres peut se féliciter la qualité de
notre système de santé
le fait qu'on n'a pas trop par rapport à
d'autres pays une médecine à deux
vitesses quand même que quand vous êtes
modeste vous avez accès à une médecine
de très bonne qualité que et sans coût
évidemment on a que là on est à mille
kilomètres mille années-lumière des
états unis de ce point de vue là donc
états unis essayent de rattraper un
petit peu cette différence est là encore
une fois c'est cetc absence
d'investissement c'est sous
investissement chronique depuis
longtemps notamment dans l'éducation
mais mais vous avez raison on a là un
grand système de redistribution mais on
a aussi un pays où les inégalités de
revenus sont parmi les plus grands
également évidemment ce système de
redistribution est là pour tempérer cet
écart je n'ai pas l'impression qu'il le
temps perd autant qu'on le dit mais il
le temps perd ça c'est sûr françois
boulot oui bah c'est bien je vous
remercie ce que c'était mon premier
argument c'est que effectivement la
répartition primaire des revenus elle
l'une des plus inégalitaires dans le
monde heureusement qu'on a un système
effectivement assez redistributif
maintenant ce qui explique ce décalage
dans cette réduction des inégalités avec
le système redistributif c'est qu'on
compare les 10% les plus pauvres avec
les 10% les plus aisés sauf que le
problème c'est que la concentration des
richesses ça se fait surtout dans les
mains d un pour cent et même des 0,1
pour cent c'est vraiment au sein de
cette classe sociale des 0 1% les plus
riches que les inégalités explosent et
ça on a un rapport notamment du comité
d'évaluation de france stratégie qui
nous explique par exemple que pour
l'année 2018 on a eu une augmentation de
leurs revenus de 27 5% alors que en
comparaison avec le reste de la
population on est entre 3 et 5%
et puis il ya une autre statistique
qu'on entend souvent mais qui avait été
donnée par le journal challenges
on sait pas le journal le plus lu
bolchévique du pays et qui nous explique
en 1996 des 500 familles les plus
fortunées de france a compté pour 6,7
pour cent dans le pays des français en
2017 elles sont passées à 25% et en 2018
elles sont passées à 30% et je voudrais
prendre olivier babeau qui nous explique
que finalement en france on serait pas
dans le néolibéralisme
mais c'est une plaisanterie et moi je
fais partie de la classe moyenne
supérieure c'est-à-dire c'est elle qui
est en soutien des classes dominantes et
qui croient dans les dogmes économiques
et dans quelle drogue mais économique
croit-elle moi je n'ai justement
identifié cinq qui caractérise ce
qu'elle néolibéralisme aujourd'hui dans
la tête des gens de monsieur et madame
tout le monde
et donc c'est la croissance y a que la
croissance qui peut apporter le pouvoir
d'achat c'est la concurrence c'est à
dire que l'état c'est mal c'est à dire
très mal et que le secteur privé qui est
performant et compétitif
il ya l'austérité c'est à dire que la
dette mon dieu l'état est en faillite et
ce fardeau va peser sur les générations
futures et à l'attractivité c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas imposer des plus
riches comme les autres sinon ils vont
quitter le pays et l'économie va
s'effondrer
puis enfin il ya la flexibilité du
marché du travail parce que finale au
coût du travail serait trop chère en
france et qu' il faudrait donc faciliter
les licenciements pour baisser le coût
du travail
et puis aussi sanctionner plus les
chômeurs parce qu'ils sont trop
feignants pour vouloir travailler on
sait 5 d'hommes et économique les
classements supérieurs ils sont
totalement acquise
et ça c'est bien la définition du
néolibéralisme et ce qui est par exemple
est en train de nous polluer l'esprit
depuis des années et ce avec quoi les
etats-unis sont en train de rompre
c'est avec ce chantage à la dette non il
n'ya pas un problème de dette publique
en france a fait des
on nous explique que la france et serait
le plus mauvaise élève de la classe
il faut arrêter avec cet argument vous
comparer le niveau d'endettement public
de la france avec les etats unis le
japon la chine l'espagne l'italie etc
etc et tous les pays déjà cités ont un
niveau d'endettement public supérieur à
celui de la france
donc il faut arrêter avec ça et je le
dis parce que on a eu un rapport arthuis
là qui vient de sortir et qui nous
explique qu'il va falloir faire un plan
drastique d'austérité pour rembourser
des dettes re coded
mais arrêtons de se moquer du monde la
dette l'endettement public a augmenté
dans les mêmes proportions dans
l'ensemble des pays du monde
donc il n'y a aucun risque de
solvabilité du pays il n'y a aucun
risque que les marchés financiers
dégrade la note de la france où pourront
toujours emprunter à des taux très
intéressants d'ailleurs il ya des taux
qui sont négatifs aujourd'hui donc
arrêtons avec cet argument de la dette
et je serais curieux d'entendre olivier
babeau nous expliquer si l'état est en
faillite parce que les données que je
viens de de données elles sont
incontestables olivier babeau sachant
qu'on nous aurons on a bien compris
quand même maintenant que le problème
c'est la charge de la dette
ce qu'on rembourse chaque mois c'est pas
la totalité de la dette qu'on nous a un
peu abusé dans ce domaine en comparant
justement la totalité de la dette avec
avec les revenus de l'état il ya eu une
véritable manipulation dans ce domaine
non il ya surtout en fait des vraies
questions économiques qui se posent vous
savez quand la règle des 3% de déficit
depuis les 60 % d'endettement avait été
fixée c'est parce qu'on avait fait un
calcul économique à l'époque qui
pensaient que c'était les limites de
soutenabilité bon ce qui est vrai c'est
que tout ça dépend de beaucoup de choses
à dire que la soutenabilité d'une dette
sa dépendent énormément de choses ça
dépend de votre croissance potentielle
en tout cas de notre croissance sur le
long terme ça dépend aussi des taux
d'intérêt est évidemment dire que si
demain à lyon il y remonte
ça peut devenir la charge de la dette
peut devenir très élevé aujourd'hui
c'est extraordinaire quand on on sait où
on fait rouler la dette d'arbres quand
on serait en dette pour payer la dette
d'avant on s'endette à taux plus bas
c'est à dire que sa baisse en fait notre
en effet le coût de la dette
et ça c'est extraordinaire mais moi
j'aimerais bien croire à l'argent
magique et puis j'aimerais bien croire
aussi aux taux zéro ou taux négatifs
pour toujours mais j'ai beaucoup de mal
à croire que le
taux d'intérêt qui est pris de l'argent
soit durablement dans cette situation
extrêmement étonnant où il est inversé
alors on parlait tout à l'heure vous
parlez de concentration des richesses
est tout à fait exact
j'en parle dans mon livre sur le premier
à mon alarme et il ya beaucoup d'effets
qui joue sur cette concentration d'avoir
la croissance de la taille des marchés
qui fait que la croissance des les plus
gros de fortes des plus grosses fortunes
vont souvent avec et dans l'histoire
c'est souvent corrélée à la taille des
marchés bon et puis il ya un effet tout
bête c'est que cette création monétaire
massive
vous savez qu'elle a une conséquence
c'est qu'elle fait monter les prix des
actifs donc les gens font pas d'actifs
c'est zéro et quand vous avez des actifs
c'est-à-dire l'immobilier ou évidemment
des actifs financiers
eh bien ces actifs augmente c'est ce
qu'on voit d'ailleurs en ce moment avec
une bourse n'a jamais été aussi haute et
puis l'immobilier qui continue ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une bulle mais on sait
pas vraiment si ça va exploser ou pas
parce que c'est là que se retrouvent
cette création monétaire extraordinaire
ça c'est un autre problème sur lequel il
faut ouvrir les yeux doux en effet il
faut pas être dogmatique sur le montant
d'une dette et aujourd'hui je crois
vraiment les dépenses de l'état et
l'importance des dépenses de l'état que
t'es fait pour soutenir le coc vide
était nécessaire en revanche il faut
faire très attention parce que le
retournement peut arriver sûr qu'il ya
un jour la signature de la france peut
en effet être dégradée les inquiétudes
peuvent remonter l'écart de taux par
rapport à ce qu'on demande sur les taux
allemands par exemple peut monter pour
d'autres pays où des sites et l'italie
par exemple ou pour évidemment parler de
la grèce satin quiétude et peut arriver
et à un moment donné il faut faire
attention parce que les gens puissent
changer d'avis sur sur la dette vous
savez que si la signature de la france
aujourd'hui est si bonne
si on nous prête si facilement c'est
parce que les gens en confiance dans la
capacité du système fiscal est dans la
force de la france encore aujourd'hui
d'aller finalement continuer à
rembourser mais attention car
l'élastique ce temps jusqu'aux jo où ils
cassent voilà je n'ai pas l'impression
d'être déraisonnable en disant ça moi
j'ai plutôt l'impression celui qui pense
à l'argent magique sans fin et au fait
que l'on puisse qu'on ne peut appeler ça
austérité mais le fait de dépenser plus
qu'on a il ya un moment donné où je suis
désolé je suis peut-être bouché à
l'émeri mais je ne vois pas comment ça
peut fonctionner mais il faut quand même
rappeler que la charge de la dette a
beaucoup baissé depuis 30 ans même si la
dette elle a augmenté mais comme on est
un pays qu'on
rappaz est effectivement on peut faire
rouler la dette comme vous l'avez dit
c'est à dire qu'on peut continuer de
s'endetter pour rembourser la dette
puisqu'il y aura toujours quelqu'un qui
paiera à la fin et qui paiera la charge
de la dette en espérant que la charge de
la dette va continuer de baisser et pas
d'augmenter si on a augmenté les taux
d'intérêt voilà comme c'est plus clair
c'est mieux de le dire mais sachez voilà
il faut savoir chaque année ces huit
fois le budget de la justice la charge
de la dette
voilà donc la belle sait rien et quand
même les taux d'intérêts à payer de
temps en temps et françois boulot est ce
que ce serait pas mieux aussi et et
d'arrêter la démagogie dit par exemple
que les gens se sont considérablement
les multimilliardaires les ultra-riches
les 1% se sont considérablement enrichis
pour la crise du coc vide
non c'est juste que un certain nombre de
valeurs financières et bien immobilier
ont augmenté
ils ont pas gagné de l'argent comment
elle comme on le lit à tord et à travers
comme s'il avait amassé de l'argent sur
des sous des matelas oui alors je vais
répondre à votre question mais juste
avant je m'étonne parce que olivier
babeau qui est un libéral
c'est étonnant sur la dette il nous
explique qu'il fait pas référence à la
loi de l'offre et la demande
et pourtant c'est ça qui se passe la
dette c'est un prix le seul problème de
la soutenabilité de la dette c'est
qu'elles notent les marchés financiers
vont donner à la france
et dans ce cadre là évidemment les
marchés financiers tiennent compte du
marché mondial des dettes publiques et
donc fixes en fonction des santés
économiques respectives des différents
pays
donc quand tous les pays augmente en
même temps leur endettement public dans
les mêmes proportions et bien la loi de
l'offre et de la demande fait que votre
natel et pas du tout dégradé vous êtes
toujours dans les mêmes niveaux
ça c'était la première chose la deuxième
pour répondre à votre à votre question
en fait vous faites référence à la
création monétaire au quantitative
easing un qui est pratiqué par la banque
centrale européenne
et effectivement c'est un énorme
problème que nous avons ou des
liquidités immense inondent les marchés
financiers ce qui crée des bulles ce qui
crée une inflation des actifs
effectivement financier mais aussi
mobilier alors les actifs financiers
c'est ce qui valorise énormément le
patrimoine de ces milliardaires
et puis le
l'inflation de l'immobilier bas c'est ce
qui fait en particulier que le niveau de
vie baisse pour une partie de la
population parce que les logements coûte
de plus en plus cher toujours est il que
par conséquent on est dans une situation
abracadabrantesque
parce que on a une idée économiques ont
été mises à l'arrêt ou en tout cas qu'on
subit une des normes restrictions et
donc on a connu des récession historique
et dans le même temps on a les marchés
financiers qui eux n'arrêtent pas de
s'envoler
donc évidemment ça ça va pas durer il ya
un moment de voir un autre il va falloir
que les vrais prix en fête soit donnée
et comme les actifs réels dans la
société sont totalement décorrélé des
masses d'argent colossales qui circulent
dans les marchés financiers
la chute elle va être terrible et là je
pose la question si olivier babeau parce
que il occulte le débat sur l'union
européenne
mais finalement le quantitative easing
que vous critiquez moi je suis d'accord
avec vous mais alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait parce que on n'a pas eu le choix
après la crise grecque pour sauver
l'euro on n'a pas le choix que de faire
le quantitative easing c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on fait là de la création
monétaire en fait tourner la planche à
billets pour sauver l'euro c'est pour ça
qu'on le fait donc on a inversé en fait
le fait que l'euro est un instrument est
pas une fin en soi
donc on fait quoi on regarde l'europe à
ce que pour garder l'euro faut continuer
à faire la planche à billets ce qui va
créer des bulles financières sur les
actifs et l'inflation de l'immobilier ou
est-ce qu'on sort de l'euro moi c'est
une question je voudrais poser parce que
en l'état on est pris dans un cirque là
un cycle infernal dont on n'arrivera pas
à ceux à se sortir
et en plus de ça dans l'euro on a une
certaine politique économique qui nous
est imposée par l'union européenne par
la commission et vous le voyez même le
fonds monétaire international est en
train de dire attention attention les
instances européennes
vous n'êtes pas en train de relancer
assez fort vos économies vous allez
subir 50% de plus de séquelles défini
des négatifs de la crise du comité de la
crise économique qui arrivent par
rapport aux autres pays
donc moi je j'alerte jeudi que l'union
européenne
là est véritablement pourrait sortir de
l'histoire est balayé et prendre un
retard considérable et notamment on a vu
que les orientations économiques été
prise nous ont fait totalement passé à
côté de la révolution numérique c'est
pas seulement l'évolution technologique
qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui on est
dépassée par la chine et des états unis
c'est simplement parce que l'union
européenne qui étaient là pour nous
défendre
dans le cadre de la mondialisation pour
paris productif pour créer aussi des
géants capables de concurrencer les
américains et les chinois à l'union
européenne elle a totalement failli
parce qu'elle ne se base pas sur la
coopération mais sur une compétition
sauvage et déloyal et ces questions là
je dire au delà de néolibéralisme
libéralisme etc ou de bureaucratisation
de l'état ces questions là qu'il faut
poser c'est comment on fait pour créer
de la valeur dans notre pays pour
garantir le maintien du niveau de vie de
la population
oui je partage ce diagnostic sur cette
incapacité de l'europe alors je sais pas
à quoi l'attribuer est ce que c'est
c'est pas justement un manque de
coopération sans doute entre les pays
c'est avec les histoires sont très très
longue qu'on a des cultures qui sont
très très différentes on est très bien
très très loin évidemment des états unis
où il ya quand même une certaine
homogénéité c'est tout à fait vrai on a
loupé tous les tournants on est en train
de louper et de ne pas posséder toutes
les sources des richesses et de
souveraineté à terme c'est extrêmement
inquiétant les biotechnologies
intelligence artificielle
en effet tout ce qui est laid liés à la
santé c'est des choses qu'on va devoir
acheter demain et qui vont devoir et
qu'on va vraiment devoir payer et pas au
prix que voudra bien nous faire le
vendeur c'est c'est très inquiétant
parce que on n'a pas encore parler
réellement de souveraineté mais c'est
bien ça la question
c'est dans ce monde qui est en train de
naître quelles sont les conditions je
crois qu'avec le coc vide on s'en est
aperçu quelles sont les conditions pour
qu'on soit encore capable de prendre nos
propres décisions et on a bien vu que
c'était extrêmement difficile même quand
l'europe a essayé de s'y mettre il l'a
fait la fée pour les vaccins de façon
très maladroite et c'est terrible pour
nous c'est terry même comme signal que
la grande-bretagne sentir sentir si bien
au moment même où elle vient de quitter
le bateau je crois qu'il est possible de
se reprendre alors oui c'est vrai il ya
plein de il ya plein de il ya plein de
manquement à l'europe oui on a été on
est resté au milieu du chemin on a fait
une usure une union économique alors
qu'eux on n'avait pas d'union politique
on a sans doute surévalué la capacité de
nausées nos économies a convergé on
saura pas ce qui se serait passé sans
100 euros probablement on aurait
beaucoup beaucoup d'évaluer les
dévaluations c'est pas toujours drôle
surtout pour les gens qui vit avec une
augmentation très très forte
devaux importations et puis du prix des
importations
avec derrière des effets sur les
exportations qui sont pas sur ce qui est
certain et comme vous avez tout à fait
raison le dire c'est qu'il faut aussi de
déterminer les conditions de la
prospérité à terme ces conditions de la
prospérité qui font aussi qu'on va
continuer à nous prêter c'est la
capacité à continuer à générer de la
valeur avoir des entreprises qui vont
gagner des marchés à l'étranger qui vont
vendre des produits et des services qui
sont qui ont de la plus haute valeur
possible et pour ça on doit miser
évidemment sur notre système de
formation sur leur capacité à coopérer
sur les rapports entre l'état et le
privé la capacité à financer des
recherches et donc avoir une vision
stratégique de ce qui se passe je crois
que c'est vraiment ça qui nous a manqué
jusqu'à présent en europe
alors je voudrais qu'on finisse sur le
cas déjà femme parce que joe biden l'a
aussi s'attaque aux gars femmes on l'a
vu sur twitter encourager les les
travailleurs d'abba zone en alabama à
mieux se faire entendre en se syndiquant
ça c'est un secret c'est un sacré
changement
on l'a entendu aussi se plaindre que à
septembre deux gars femme ne paient pas
assez d'impôts fédérale aux états unis
on sait qu'il veut on la dit augmenter
les impôts des entreprises mais qu'il
veut les a augmenté partout dans le
monde et c'est ce dont se charge sa
secrétaire au trésor
et on sait quand les américains veulent
imposer quelque chose au monde
ils en ont les moyens françois boulot là
encore joe biden gilet jaune d'honneur
je crois qu au moins il a peut-être le
mérite d'essayer de réguler un peu sega
femmes ces monstres économiques y sont
nés et qui comme vous le disiez sont
l'incarnation de la puissance du marché
face face aux états et donc c'est très
bien qu'on ait enfin se signale la
lancée par les états unis la première
puissance mondiale et j'espère
effectivement qu'on va vers un début de
régulation moi ce qui m'interpelle c'est
que à la l'issue de la seconde guerre
mondiale on a créé des instances
internationales de régulation n'avaient
notamment britton woods pour réguler la
monnaie et le fmi contrôler
était en charge de ce contrôle là et
puis à la faveur effectivement des
années 70 sous du ralentissement de
l'économie mondiale américaine
on a eu la fin des accords de
bretton-woods décidée unilatéralement
par les états unis et on est rentré dans
une ère où finalement les états se sont
mis de moins en moins à coopérer et il
est bien évident que cette désunion des
états elle a aussi permis au marché de
prospérer de gagner en influence parce
que à mesure que les états ne coopérez
pu internationalement alors le marché
bénéficier de ces des régulations
internationales pour et bien finalement
imposé sa loi dans les états en juin sur
le dumping social et fiscal
donc tout ce qui peut appeler à une
régulation au niveau mondial qui
passerait par une coopération des états
j'y suis évidemment tout à fait
favorable et ce mouvement là il est tout
à fait à rebours des orientations
politiques et même théorique de l'union
européenne et je veux clarifier un point
parce que olivier babeau disait qu'on
n'a pas fait ligne en politique mais on
ne peut pas faire l'union politique
c'est ça que le drame qu'on a depuis des
années c'est que on ne peut pas mettre
des instances démocratiques au sein de
l'union européenne pour une raison
simple il n'existe pas de peuple
européen
il n'y a que des peuples nationaux il ya
un peuple français un peuple espagnol un
peuple allemand et voyez moi si d'ici
demain
on avait imaginé un référendum entre
l'allemagne et la france sur la question
du système de protection sociale au
hasard et imaginons que l'allemagne
gagne ce référendum parce qu'ils sont
plus nombreux et que les du coup ça
implique une baisse on va dire de 2 du
niveau de protection sociale de 20 à 30%
pour les français mais moi je suis pas
d'accord pour me soumettre à la décision
des allemands et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de français qui sont pas
d'accord pour se soumettre à cette
décision des allemands
donc la démocratie n'est pas possible
puisque la minorité n'acceptera pas de
se soumettre à la loi de la majorité
et en plus de cela dans une démocratie
pour pouvoir résoudre les conflits et de
manière apaisée et trouver des consensus
il faut pouvoir débattre donc ça existe
déjà d'avoir une langue commune
nous n'avons pas cette langue comme il
nous ne pouvons pas faire la démocratie
au niveau de l'union européenne et par
conséquent on est à un carrefour
et je le dis parce que la deutsche bank
explique que dans les dix ans c'est
l'âge du désordre qui s'avance deux
hommes devant nous et l'union européenne
pourrait imploser
et elle ajoute que la pire
erreur serait de poursuivre les mêmes
orientations qui ont été faites depuis
vingt ou trente ans ça veut dire que là
il faut une logique de rupture avec les
règles des orientations de l'union
européenne parce que sinon on n'arrivera
jamais à prendre le wagon qui est en
train de gérer d'initiés que sont en
train d'initier les états unis et on va
encore passer à côté comme on est en
train de passer à côté de l'histoire
depuis vingt ou trente ans olivier
babeau alors tout sur la question des
gaffes un qui était avec les questions
initiales et clic est vraiment
intéressante parce qu'il ya vraiment
quelque chose qui se passe enfin et je
crois qu'on était très nombreux à le
réclamer et finalement cette réclamation
elle est partie de l'europe 1 ça fait un
moment que l'europe essaye de de faire
pièce c'est compliqué jusque là on
n'avait pas vraiment les idées les idées
claires et puis on n'avait pas le bon
dispositif et baï donne maintenant va
nous aider mais attention c'est pas pour
enrichir l'europe parce que quand il
veut augmenter l'imposition son idée
c'est que c'est trésor américain qui
prend la différence attention hein
il ne redistribue pas bon évidemment
c'est pour l'intérêt américain america
first sassano ça n'a pas bougé
en fait ces petites histoires dégâts
face c'est très intéressant parce que
c'est une épiphanie des préoccupations
libéral 1 puisque contre les monopoles
on dit il faut plus de concurrence
il faut faire pièce aux monopoles qui
ces plateformes par effet d'agrégation
et grâce à la loi de metcalfe qui font
plus utiliser un réseau c'est égal au
carré du nom d'utilisateur font qu'il ya
ce qu'on appelle une sorte de ba2
gagnant prend tout un défi du gagnant
prend tous des plateformes et on essaye
de réfléchir à des moyens pour éviter
cette monopolisation bon les gars face à
nous attire aussi l'attention sur
d'autres valeurs qui sont
extraordinairement libéral comment on va
arriver à reprendre le contrôle sur la
trace sur notre attention
comment on va arriver à maintenir la
liberté d'expression et le débat
démocratique
comment on va aussi protéger notre vie
privée contre le capitalisme de
surveillance tout ça c'est des combats
qu'on doit mener aujourd'hui est en fait
c'est les préoccupations libéral depuis
toujours et puis la place de l'état qui
nous protège donc finalement je suis
très content de cette évolution de la
situation par ha par rapport aux de
confort boulot mais je suis assez
heureux qu'olivier babeau parle
notamment de capitalisme de surveillance
parce que moi j'analyse que le
néolibéralisme la dynamique dans
laquelle on est depuis trente ou
quarante ans est en train de faire
s'effondrer la légitimité des autorités
des institutions
ce qu' elle crée trop de pauvreté trop
de déclassement dans la population
française et à mesure que la légitimité
du pouvoir ça fesse alors l'autorail
l'autoritarisme progresse dans la
société et on a vu des digues franchi en
terme d'atteinte aux libertés
depuis l'arrivée notamment au pouvoir
des manuels macron avec les gilet jaune
ça a été une évidence notamment dans le
traitement des manifestations et de la
répression policière et judiciaire qui
s'était abattu mais pas seulement on a
aussi des idées des atteintes aux
libertés de la presse et comme le disait
olivier babeau le cap et c'est le
capitalisme de surveillance qui nous
menace parce que aujourd'hui on a les
moyens avec les gars femme de
d'organiser une surveillance massive des
citoyens on peut collecter toutes sortes
de données permet de tout savoir et moi
ce que je redoute c'est si on sait que
si on continue sur cette dynamique là on
pourrait aller sur un scénario peut-être
à la chinoise où vous avez un passeport
citoyen et vous êtes noter vous avez des
points et puis si vous critiquez
gouvernement vous êtes un mauvais
citoyen et les sanctions c'est que ce
soit vous avez plus de répondre la ville
le prendre l'avion soit vous n'avez plus
droit d'accéder à un crédit pour acheter
votre logement ou votre entreprise
bref ce qui menacerait ce serait
l'ostracisation sociale des individus
qui seraient divergent et je crois que
on ne pourra pas résoudre cette question
là autrement qu'en changeant les
orientations économiques qu'en remettant
de la justice fiscale et sociale pour
pour dire les choses simplement de les
quitter qu'à nouveau les gens aient
l'impression que la rémunération se fait
véritablement au mérite et non pas
suivant des privilèges et des
accointances et des logiques de réseau
et d'entre eux soit qui mine la
légitimité du pouvoir et je crois qu'il
faut absolument sortir de cette spirale
qui est mortifère et rompre avec le
néolibéralisme pour sauver la liberté ça
je crois que c'est peut-être une des
urgences les plus grandes aujourd'hui
dans notre pays
rompons avec le néolibéralisme parce que
sinon demain nous nous retrouvons
vraiment sous une forme très autoritaire
pour ne pas dire totalitaires dans notre
pays olivier dernier mot oui moi j'ai
des sentiments je suis content qu'on
termine par la queue en fait derrière
des étiquettes qui sont souvent
trompeuses en fait on est assez d'accord
et on est assez convergent sur cette
idée que le grand danger aujourd'hui
c'est cet affaiblissement terrible des
régimes représentatifs des régimes des
démocraties libérales en fait face à des
démocraties où des régimes libéraux dont
on voit bien que
ils ont accumulé beaucoup de points
positifs pendant la crise ils ont déjà
démontré une capacité stratégique
capacité d'anticipation et capacité de
réaction que malheureusement les
vieilles démocratie délibérative ont du
mal aujourd'hui à porter donc le grand
enjeu de ce début de siècle là c'est
d'arriver à avoir un régime
représentatif qui regagne effectivement
on légitimité en vision stratégique en
capacité à organiser les choses afin
qu'il démonte plus que jamais qu'il est
un régime qui peut continuer à faire
pièce à des régimes plus plus plus
autoritaire c'est ma grande
préoccupation effectivement aujourd'hui
et on voit bien que c'est le thème de la
liberté dont il est question c'est
comment on va conserver la liberté de
l'individu et ça c'est la première
évidemment des convictions la première
des valeurs chez les libéraux je vous
remercie tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]